we are with Bogdan Daniel the
acromania's number to Bogdan first of
all a difficult tournament up to this
point for you but today a pretty solid
result against Anish you got some
pressure out of the opening did you
prepare this with your coach this idea
of Bishop E2 Bishop F3 this uh obscure
line in in the neither of one would say
okay hello hello first of all thank you
for the invitation
I prepare a bit this idea with Bishop F3
okay yeah just to see
H6 Bishop F3 it's the normal move so
what are some of the ideas of this
bishop E2 Bishop F3 plan
to come with A4 A5 92 Knight F1 ig3 okay
yeah
yes and you actually play that yes so
let's take a look at
the continuation The Rook to E2 gather
work on the D file is is it to put
pressure on the D6 Pawn or rather to
stop black from playing D5
what is the main idea behind this both
things to stop D5 and to put pressure on
D6 Pawn
did you feel like he was ready for this
okay it's a bit unpleasant because in a
normally we want to try D5 it yes in
neither yes
but by the way did you expect him to
play the night off yes you did yes so
you thought he's going to
try for a Sharp game today
okay I don't want really a sharp game
today I just want to play normal yes yes
okay Knight to C1
and in fact the engine was giving you a
pretty decent lead at this point
plus one were you feeling that this is a
plus close to a plus one advantage right
now okay you don't feel really plus one
but I feel plus you were feeling like
you are putting the pressure yes yes
probably here I need to bring instead of
B3 to try H3 so Queen B7
Knight G3
here if I try and just to interrupt you
for a second I do believe
we just got a result right now and in
fact
Wesley saw for whatever reason accepted
a draw in this position
unbelievable result he was in fact much
better and perhaps even winning at this
point and he decided to repeat this is
in fact unbelievable turn of events but
we'll we'll catch up with all that drama
in just a second let's finish the
analysis bogdon I think we we left it
off somewhere around here
please continue yes instead of D3 I
think at H3 Queen B7 Knight G3
here I think at B3 also my T4 C4 Knight
C7
Queen C2 F5 Knight C3 and D5
I don't know what to say because cd5
doesn't work because of my D2 and D4 D4
yeah yeah and you cannot take only six
because if I takes F3 with the check yes
okay
very nice good calculation uh you decide
to go for this B3
and
okay probably don't need to play Knight
F5 probably just to continue to play
room T3 repeating Queen Nifty
but here I don't like Nike it and come
with Knight on F6 probably the best move
but yes
the engine as well so definitely you
kind of understood exactly what the
requirements of the position uh are and
by the way it's not despite the fact
that the engine is saying that sure
you're better it's not that easy right
yes you make a dent in in Black's
position cool all right and you guys
exchanged
did anything out of the ordinary happen
in your opinion or at this point you
both had to more or less repeat the
position okay here it's necessary to
read it
because you know I put the G4 yeah I
can't I can't I can become easy worse
here we try it yes yes Bogdan uh
congratulations up to this point you're
finishing up with Richie Rapport I
believe uh Stingley ran in the last one
the world champion and there is another
player that you will be facing I don't
remember exactly
nvl quite a difficult finish how are you
going to approach those games
okay I just try to play just try to play
and by the way uh right now the Romanian
national team is having a new coach
Yvonne sokolov he was uh on the other
broadcast as well how is that
partnership going are you enjoying
working with Mr sokolov
IC it's a good relationship
I don't want to see more of course of
course well thank you very much well
done thank you and we'll see you in the
upcoming rounds thank you guys back you
Christian thank you